we don't hate Taylor Swift
we hate the unabashed,
idolatrous,
cult-like worship of her
that's what we hate
that's what we are annoyed by
she might be a fine person
she might be a nice person
I have absolutely no idea
her music might be fine to some people
there are a few songs that I like
but none of us know her well enough to say if we hate her or love her
or know her character or anything
like come on
but Taylor Swift is not the problem
it's the people who say that they will vote for whoever she votes for
it's you people
it's the people putting Taylor Swift shirts on Jesus
and literally worshipping this girl that they've never met
that they don't know anything about
they would do anything for her that is
that is what's annoying
that's what's weird
and it's fine to think that.
we don't know
we can't hate her
so when the Swifties are like
“you guys hate her so much” like
we don't hate her
we don't know her well enough to hate her or to love her
nobody hates her
we hate the worship of her